Liz truss will announce a freeze to  average domestic energy bills at 2 500  pounds for up to two years now Universal  grants of 400 pounds already announced  by Rishi sunac will still apply bringing  that down to 2 100 pounds close to the  current price cap of  1971 but without intervention that  figure will rise 80 to  3549 pounds and to stop that increase  the government will borrow to make up  the difference between the capped figure  and the real cost to suppliers of buying  energy so taxpayer money will go to  energy companies to pay for our bills  now the cost of filling that gap for all  households would be about 40 billion  pounds a year but that's without any  further price rises in wholesale gas  markets government sources say the total  package won't exceed a hundred billion  pounds a year but it is impossible to  accurately predict the cost because of  the volatility of energy markets and  there will be concern this could be a  blank check funding energy company  profits